foreign
Squad to Toledo Ohio and talk to
Brittany what's up Brittany how we doing
good how are you partying man what are
you up to
you that's not true
lunch break early lunch break yeah
talking to you all right I was gonna say
your boss is the worst but this is like
a late breakfast break but let's go hey
whatever whatever works what's happening
how are you
good I am excited to hear uh maybe some
advice from you
um I think that physical abuse is in my
future from my husband
and my question is
how can I get get my husband to get
professional help
when I also you know kind of fear Him
and I'm afraid to make him angry in that
encouragement to do that
did you did you write this question down
before you called
okay when you practiced it
did it feel insane as it came out of
your mouth
and I mean that like in a fun way like
and I mean not like you know I'm
pointing at you but like in a are you
hearing what you're saying
this phone call is very difficult for me
to make okay because
I think that I've tried to convince
myself that it's not that bad but I made
myself Journal after this last fight
because I didn't want to forget like
it's it's getting too too scary Brittany
get out
yeah
I'm hey and listen you know me I'm
always laughing carrying on you gotta
get out
what you were saying is I'm about to be
assaulted I'm about to be abused
what can I do
what what is one story I can finally
tell him what is one thing in the
bedroom I can finally what's one thing I
can do
so that this person doesn't do a highly
irrational
illegal act
against a violence against me and the
answer is nothing get out
you gotta get out
why does that sound insane to you
I
it's it sounds crazy because I have seen
progress in our marriage
um but this last fight scared you
yeah yeah
so there's not progress you're telling
yourself stories why
yeah why
are you scared of what's on the other
side are you scared of being alone what
are you scared of
I and it's okay to be scared of all that
stuff right
um we are very
committed Christ followers I disagree I
100 disagree
I don't believe you
yeah because Christ followers don't beat
their wives
yeah they don't they take a knee
all right they go get help
right and so you've got a bunch of
different voices you've got your church
barking in your ear you've got
knuckle-headed friends who just keep
repeating things that should be stitched
on pillows to you you've got misguided
devotional guy whatever
you gotta get out you're worth being
safe
home should be a place where you get off
your after your early lunch break and
you go back to whatever job you're doing
you go home
and you you're you're you're you smile
as you walk in the door because it's
such a safe warm place
even if it has
yes
at some point you got to stop blaming
yourself you got to stop coming up with
stories to defend this guy
all right absolutely not a Christ
follower
and I would say that if he was sitting
right here in front of me
he's using that as cover to do whatever
he wants to do in your life
what are you scared of
I mean serious I'm being serious
because I want to do it I want to do
what I can in this short call to pull to
pull right to shine some light on that
fear and let you know that it's probably
toothless
he
like fixed on his end because it's not
there can be but he's got to do the work
yeah you can't do anything
who he is I think it's an ability that
he's able to get to no no no
um Brittany
stop defending him
stop
you've been defending him to your
friends and you've been defending him to
your family for a long time it doesn't
work with me stop
yeah
yeah any man
who has a wife
who is in believes that she can be
physically injured at any moment
is not a person of character
all right
period
and I've expressed this to him uh like
my fear I've told him like you know this
is the path that it looks like it's
going down
of course any person in that situation
would say I never want to do that so
um and he did and I like and I've
created has he hit you
no
no how close has he got
just our fights have gotten to the point
where it's
has he hit the wall by you
right
or like broken things get out or like
get out
until he stops acting like a
nine-year-old on a bus stop
get out yeah
you've got to be safe Brittany because
here's why you're not gonna sleep
yeah your body's not gonna let you
because it's trying to stay safe it's
trying to not die
um
and you've Pro how long have you been
with this dude
five years
and how long did you date before that
two
so by now in these situations you are
highly isolated true or false
say it 50th innocence but but I I have
surrounded myself with good people I'm
not do they know
like one
okay
you are completely alone in this deal
it is what happens this is what happens
it's a common story it's a common
refrain you start protecting yourself
and eventually your friends say I can't
be a part of this or there's something
about this dude that I don't like and
you get mad at them or they get mad at
you and you begin to slowly that that
circle of influence gets Tighter and
Tighter and Tighter and Tighter
and I don't know you you could walk into
this room right now and I wouldn't know
because I've never seen you I have no
idea who this person is but I've heard
this story too much
and when I say get out that doesn't mean
forever
what that means is you have the only
thing on planet Earth you can control is
your thoughts and your actions that's it
true and your actions right now are to
be safe and you are not safe in your own
bed you're not safe in your own living
room you're not safe in your own kitchen
You're Not Safe in your own home get out
find a place where you can be safe
yeah and then he and only he has some
significant choices about the therapy
he's gonna go get
right about the
um mentorship he's gonna get he's gonna
have to deal with his addictions because
I guarantee you he's got some guaranteed
he's got to deal with his anger he's
gonna have to deal with his childhood
mess he's got to deal with all of it
and listen to me super carefully I
absolutely one thousand percent do not
care what he does or doesn't want to do
I care what he does
right
I've talked to I've
I've never met somebody who wants to hit
their wife
but they're right but they do
get out okay and I tell you that because
I love you and if he was sitting right
here right next to me I would tell him
your wife needs to go away while you get
safe
and if he wants to call me I would love
to talk to him not in a mean Macho way
but just like I I don't think he wants
to be the guy he is but
Brittany he is the guy he is
okay
will you get will you commit just just
on this call will you commit to find in
a way to be safe go stay with a
girlfriend for two or three or four
weeks
it's usually a minimum of 30 days all
right
because it's not it I mean you're saying
something that I haven't thought about
but like it's not up to me no to like
encourage him no you get get the help no
right
a murder victim doesn't encourage her
murderer to stop murdering right that's
not right
he or she has to decide to not murder
right
because listen I want you to follow this
track when you say there's not anything
I can do to encourage him what you're
doing is you are saying this abuse him
smashing the wall behind my head him
throwing crap across the house and
throwing it at me getting really close
put making a fist and balling it up
right by my face
put his hand on my neck those things are
somehow your fault
because you need some encouragement and
it's not
right
and he can wrap himself up in you just
make me so mad he can wrap himself up in
his little Jesus flag and he can wrap
himself up in whatever crap he wants to
wrap himself up in
he's a guy that's terrifying his wife
with physical violence
right you my friend Brittany I want you
to be safe
so that that's the call
only thing you can control are your
thoughts and your actions and I want you
to think about what it's going to take
for Brittany to be safe for a season and
it's probably going to take a minimum of
30 days for of you leaving and getting a
safe place to stay
and I know that for millions of people
in this country they have got a friend
or a family member they can go has a
spare room and millions and millions and
millions of people in this country have
nowhere to go maybe a friend's couch for
30 days
maybe another apartment that they can
scratch up enough pennies and nickels to
to sign a 30-day lease
and it's sketchy and scary and I know
all that it's terrifying
or maybe it's you get with your employer
and you get you with your uh employee
assistance program and you go talk to a
counselor and say I'm terrified for my
life is there any Community Resources in
my community where I live right now
but you gotta stay safe and then you'd
be very clear to him here is my
guidelines for staying in relationship
with you
if you ever threaten to hit me again
it's over I'm out if you ever ball your
fist up or smash something in this house
I'm out
if you ever scream and yell at me I'm
out if you swear at me I'm out if you
cheat on me again I'm out
because the out that's what you can
control all this other nonsense is what
he can control
you're worth being safe and you're worth
a loving warm relationship and you're
worth way more than what he's giving you
right now
choose safety
choose safety choose safety